you were saying funnily enough you're
extremely popular in india
yeah i i guess there's a lot of i guess
this information is missing in india
or something i mean i didn't really
recognize it because i don't often look
at my youtube stats to see where the
demographics are watching from but
a good chunk of the book sales came from
india on kindle which is which was
really surprising probably like
number two that is amazing yeah because
i think
india's going through this sort of
feminist like wave at the moment right
where like
rape uh laws are really
yeah did you hear about the new one
where apparently if if you're an indian
dude and you have sex with a girl
under the guise that you're interested
in her and that she believes that she
might get a marriage proposal out of it
but you don't marry her
um they can they can basically come back
and me to your ass over there
oh boy but if you you know if she wears
a push-up bra then you can't claim she
sexually assaulted you can you
nope oh god that's the female first
primary social worker and that's what
you guys need to understand
that is part of the world that we live
in right
you